je passe tout de suite à notre second
débat des bas de société volontairement
décalée de l'actu du jour on revient sur
cette proposition d'Emmanuel Macron 15
septembre dernier mieux répartir sur
tout le territoire les demandeurs
d'asile et les réfugiés qui arrivent en
France on doit avoir ce sont des manuels
Macron plusieurs d'entre vous sont des
territoires ruraux
quel que soit les engagements pris nous
devons fermer des classes
vraisemblablement des écoles et des
collèges si nous savons
offrir de l'hébergement de l'urgence et
de l'intégration dans ces régions à des
femmes et des hommes qui arrivent sur
notre sol les conditions de leur accueil
seront bien meilleur que si nous les
mettons dans des zones qui sont déjà
dansément peuplées avec une
concentration de problèmes économiques
et sociaux massif et où vous avez déjà
trop d'élèves par classe et où parfois
vous retrouvez avec des comptes qui ont
10 à 15 élèves à nos fomes
c'est ça la situation qui est la nôtre
elle est absurde l'idée n'est pas
nouvelle vous le verrez mais elle
continue de provoquer un tollé à droite
avant d'en débattre le reportage de
Flora sauvage dans un village de
l'Allier qui accueille des migrants
depuis plusieurs années
un village de 800 habitants dans la liée
ici on accueille des réfugiés qui ont
fui leur pays Ismail est arrivé il y a 6
ans de la jungle de Calais depuis il
s'est installé dans le bois d'à côté à 8
km 10 grandes
je suis arrivé
à Libye à Italie
Sainte-Marie et enfants Mustapha était
cuisinier en Syrie ira chaque comptable
en France ils ont dû repartir de zéro et
face à l'offre réduit de transport en
commun en milieu rural il aura fallu
s'adapter le fait que il n'y a pas de
transport en commun c'est il y a que un
seul bus qui part le matin c'était très
difficile si on a besoin de quelque
chose on est obligé aussi de demander
aux gens on sent vraiment que on dérange
les autres à chaque fois on a besoin
quelque chose on demande aux autres
est-ce que vous pouvez nous emmener dans
épicerie ou dans les supermarchés depuis
rachat a passé son permis de conduire
des enfants eux sont venus grossir les
rangs de l'école
c'est la manière c'est le moyen de se
sortir de leur de leurs problèmes
s'amélior rural c'est effectivement deux
éléments moteurs les enfants sont
généralement des bons élèves très
assidus et donc ça se passe relativement
bien et et ils font monter le niveau de
la classe
son mari vivre en zone rurale est un bon
moyen de s'intégrer avant peut-être un
jour de déménager en ville parmi la
centaine de réfugiés qui ont été
accueillis sur ce territoire la grande
majorité a quitté la campagne pour
s'installer en ville ou l'offre en
matière d'emploi et de transport et plus
développé
on débat donc autour de cette
proposition d'Emmanuel Macron avec Tania
Rachid bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
docteur en droit européen membre des
collectifs les surligneurs et
désinfox migration auteur de politique
immigration et réfugiés c'est aux
éditions Enrique alexandrevecchio
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes rédacteur en
chef au Figaro Matthieu tardise mon
choix bonsoir et bienvenue pardon
chercheur responsable du centre
migration et citoyenneté de l'ifril
Laetitia crupparaissent politique et
restez à mes côtés évidemment peut-être
Tania rachot pour commencer il faut dire
précisément ce qu'est la proposition ou
l'idée on va dire on verra qu'elle est
pas forcément nouvelle dans un instant
du président République ça concerne qui
oui alors c'est intéressant parce
qu'effectivement on parle parfois de la
répartition des migrants ou des
étrangers alors que en pratique la
possibilité de répartir les gens
implique nécessairement que vous leur
proposez un logement et les seuls le
seul public à qui on va proposer un
logement et bien sont les demandeurs
d'asile puis éventuellement les réfugiés
dans pas longtemps mais donc c'est un
public limité ça concerne bien entendu
pas tout le monde et les demandeurs
d'asile c'est à peu près 100 000
personnes un peu plus de 100.000
personnes par an qui arrivent et qui
demande l'asile puisque donc le temps de
que leur demande soit excusée il faut
qu'ils puissent bénéficier de conditions
de vie digne c'est demandeurs d'asile
qui c'est un public particulier enfin il
faut dire c'est un public fragile parce
que c'est le premier terme qui vous
vient à l'esprit bien entendu ce sont
donc des demandeurs d'Asie ils ont
potentiellement fui des persécutions
pour des motifs qui peuvent être très
graves ou en lien avec par exemple leur
orientation sexuelle donc c'est un
public vulnérable et cette vulnérabilité
elle est prise en compte normalement au
moment de la question justement de leur
hébergement Alexandre echo sur cette
question de du public on va dire
viser ciblée par Emmanuel Macron quand
il fait cette cette proposition
effectivement on parle des demandeurs
d'asile des réfugiés
est-ce que vous dites à partir du moment
où c'est les demoiselles d'or d'asile
c'est acceptable ou pas
plusieurs choses d'abord il faut voir
que les demandeurs d'asile beaucoup une
majorité sont des bouteilles et 80% de
ceux qui se font déboutés restent sur le
territoire déjà il y a une différence
entre quelqu'un qui sont un peu des faux
demandeurs d'Asie il y a une partie qui
sont des migrants économiques et l'État
n'a pas les moyens ensuite de les
reconduire ensuite il y a les les
réfugiés qui à qui on a accordé le
statut de réfugiés je sais pas si c'est
acceptable ou pas acceptable je pense
que ça suscite des crispations et je
pense qu'il faut voir ces crispations à
l'aune peut-être de 40 ans d'échecs de
la politique d'immigration et
d'intégration on nous a beaucoup dit ça
va bien se passer et on s'est retrouvé
avec des territoires perdus de la
République ghettoïsé alors on va nous
dire c'est un moyen finalement de
répartir la possibilité et de casser les
ghettos mais je pense que pour beaucoup
de Français la priorité aujourd'hui et
de réduire les flux de reconduire ceux
qui sont en situation
régulière de reconduire ce qui
commettent des délits et donc
ça apparaît pas la priorité de les
disperser dans toute la vie on peut pas
avoir une politique qui est équilibrée
finalement
maîtriser la politique d'immigration et
ensuite réfléchir à une politique
d'intégration mais aujourd'hui c'est
plus audible et la grande crainte d'une
partie du public et moi je la partage
c'est qu'on finalement disperse les
problèmes et qu'on délocalise les
problèmes qu'on connaît en banlieue dans
toute la France dans des coins ou
jusqu'à alors il y avait pas de problème
et rappelons que cette France aura les
périphériques assez propre problème je
dirais qu'il y a il y a des problèmes
également de d'absence de service public
d'absence de notamment en matière de
santé donc on y reviendra c'est pour ça
que tu as une crise passion et elle est
parfaitement compréhensible on y
reviendra largement on a vu dans le
reportage qu'il y a des endroits où ça
se passe bien il faut pas non plus
totalement noircir le tableau c'est
nécessairement j'ai bien entendu crainte
et que à l'aune de ce qui s'est passé
pendant 40 ans on pouvait comprendre
cette euh Matthieu TARDIS est-ce que
vous vous voyez réagir pendant que que
Alexandre de viechio donnait à leur
façon de point de vue en disant faut
demandeur d'Asie est-ce que
effectivement le chiffre de 80% qui
finalement reste sur le territoire quand
ils sont déboutés est-ce que vous les
confirmez non en fait je n'ai des
confirme ni les infirmes parce qu'en
fait il y a j'aimerais bien savoir
j'entends souvent ce chiffre là où
d'autres chiffres quels sont quels sont
alors quels sont les les sources parce
que je vois lis les ministères les
rapports du ministère de l'Intérieur ont
l'argent en travers je n'ai jamais vu et
je parle des sources du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc ça c'est je pense que
c'est une idée un peu qui est véculé
depuis des années en France comme
réalité moi je suis fier attendez
monsieur je suis chercheur je vous parle
de données qui sont publiques celles qui
sont et donc dans ces données là des
chiffres dans des émissions
on s'écoute les uns les autres donc on
va continuer de le
et moi en tant que chercheur et vous
parlerai d'autres chercheurs sur ces
questions là on n'a jamais lu ce chiffre
là et aussi tout bêtement parce qu'on
n'a pas donné sur ce que deviennent les
déboutés deviennent des étrangins en
situation irrégulière après qui est des
questions à se poser sur l'efficacité
des politiques de retour je l'admets et
c'est une autre question
sur la question aussi du lien entre le
problème de banlieue là j'ai aussi du
mal à avoir quel est le lien entre
finalement la question des réfugiés qui
arrivent aujourd'hui et les problèmes de
banlieue mais ça c'est aussi un point de
vue politique et ça je je vous le laisse
sur la question très précise dont Tanya
l'a rappelé on parle
segment très spécifique et finalement
assez limité de l'immigration en France
donc qui est lié aussi à des obligations
que tout est à en Europe et dans la
plupart de du monde c'est-à-dire de
pendant la demande d'asile de pouvoir
proposer un hébergement et on parle pas
d'un logement très très luxueux l'un
d'hébergement pendant l'examen de la
demande d'asile ça fait partie des nos
obligations au regard du droit
international aux engagements
internationaux et la France le rappelle
souvent sont devoir de protection des
réfugiés
international le droit international et
des conventions internationales ensuite
qui sont précisés au niveau européen
donc qui le précise dans ce contexte
européen et donc ça c'est c'est une
obligation la question de la répartition
des demandeurs d'asile c'est une
question qui est ancienne qui est aussi
ancienne quelque part que notre système
d'accueil des réfugiés en France on le
faisait dans les années 70 déjà quand on
appuyé les réfugiés chiliens et de
l'Asie du Sud-Est
et c'est surtout depuis les années 2000
ou les pouvoirs publics essaient de
mieux répartir et ce qui est une
concentration de la demande d'asile sur
Paris l'Île-de-France et donc pour
éviter des phénomènes que l'on observe
depuis quand même de nombreuses années
aujourd'hui de campement dans la rue
évidemment alors je vous interrompre
parce que l'historique on va le faire
tout de suite justement grâce à Audrey
beta on va on va reprendre effectivement
ce marqueur rebonsoir Audrey de des
années 70 parce que la première question
qu'on s'est posée quand on a entendu
finalement cette déclaration d'Emmanuel
Macron on s'est dit mais est-ce que
c'est une idée neuve pas vraiment non
vous l'avez dit elle date des les 70
notamment à l'époque pour accueillir les
réfugiés chiliens fuyant le coup d'État
d'Augusto Pinochet à cette période la
doctrine c'était déjà de disséminer les
centres d'hébergement sur l'ensemble des
territoires surtout dans les espaces peu
denses Thomas cette idée gagnant
puissance vous l'avez dit là aussi dans
les années 2000 et en 2015 Jean-Pierre
Raffarin l'ancien Premier ministre
sénateur LR à cette époque ça n'en parle
en pleine crise des migrants en Europe
il prône l'installation de famille
d'étrangers dans les zones rurales
écoutez c'était sur notre antenne
que l'étranger au lieu de venir déranger
il vient sauver un territoire il
participe à une dynamique et si c'est ta
dose qui sont des des doses humainement
acceptables par les uns et par les
autres l'intégration était globalement
réussi en 2016 c'est Bernard Cazeneuve
alors ministre de l'Intérieur qui défend
cette idée au moment du démantèlement de
la jungle de Calais il veut construire
de nouveaux centres d'accueil pour y
orienter les demandeurs d'asile et de
réfugiés on va regarder une carte qui
permet de se rendre compte de ce qui a
déjà été fait celle des centres
d'accueil et de demandeurs d'asile en
France il y en a dans tous les
départements métropolitains vous le
voyez mais à l'époque l'idée c'est
bondir la droite écoutez
c'est de la folie
et le sujet pas une question de
solidarité le gouvernement est pas en
train de démanteler qu'elle est on
résout pas qu'elle est on va multiplier
des Calais partout en France ce qu'on
attend du gouvernement c'est que en
fermant Calais il ne déplace pas le
problème à l'intérieur de la France mais
qu'il le résolve comme un sentiment de
déjà-vu évidemment on peut se demander
si cette dissémination est un voeux pieu
parce que ce n'est pas parce qu'on
accueille un réfugié ou un demandeur
d'asile dans un territoire qu'il va y
rester je vais terminer avec une carte
c'est la répartition des immigrés dans
les campagnes qui sont ensuite en
situation régulière régulière pardon on
voit qu'il y a une concentration au
niveau des frontières ou en périphérie
des villes là où il y a des bassins
d'emplois Thomas merci beaucoup
évidemment le je reviens vers vous
Alexandre devecchio parce que quand on
voit cette idée on l'a dit elle est pas
nouvelle elle semble elle semble
tellement simple qu'on se dit bah oui ça
ça ne peut que marcher d'un côté il y a
il y a des ghettos on l'a dit il y a
trop de population d'origine immigrées
dans des quartiers pauvres de l'autre il
y a des villages qui le désertifie et
qu'il faut voilà des écoles qui ferment
bref
colonne plus colonne moi ça va bien
ensemble sauf que c'est trop simpliste
pour vous d'une part peut-être s'il y a
20 ans je vous aurais dit oui pourquoi
pas le aujourd'hui je pense que le la
situation démographique le rapport à
l'immigration est trop compliquée et
qu'il faut commencer par remettre à plat
notre politique d'immigration d'accueil
avant de procéder à la dispersion des
populations ensuite vous l'avez bien dit
c'est pas nouveau donc en réalité on a
déjà pratiqué cette cette politique là
elle va continuer à se pratiquer tant
qu'on accueillera des gens c'est aussi
ça la question comment moi ma question
c'est comment ralentit les flux et
comment on renvoie ceux qui n'ont pas
être là je pense que ça devrait être la
priorité politique du moment donc
ensuite parler de répartition je pense
qu'on le fera de toute manière mais on
commence déjà à mesurer les effets de
cette politique on voit que les
problèmes d'insécurité on en a
aujourd'hui dans des villes de province
ça n'existait pas auparavant donc je
pense que c'est aussi une crainte je
pense qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui un
modèle satisfaisant en matière
d'intégration j'entendais les années 70
mais c'était des populations qui avaient
une culture différente peut-être plus
facilement j'allais dire compatible
immédiatement avec la nôtre on a vu
aujourd'hui que c'est qu'on avait des
phénomènes de communautarisme de
ghettoïsation y compris dans des villes
de la France périphérique ou dans des
villes de la France rurale donc je pense
que c'est inaudible alors sans doute on
va continuer à le faire ce que je dis
parce qu'il faut bien répartir les gens
mais ce que ça monte c'est que les flux
continu alors que je pense qu'il y a une
majorité de la population qui est
favorable à une politique d'équilibre
c'est-à-dire réussir à ralentir ces flux
à renvoyer ceux qui doivent être envoyés
peut-être dans un second temps réussir
en fin de politique d'intégration alors
vous voulez l'un et l'autre réagir tenir
à chaud pour commencer
le problème c'est toujours de tout
mélanger malheureusement on peut pas
maintenant tout se tient pas parce que
les demande c'est une donnée une extrait
câble à laquelle on peut on ne peut pas
dire non on étudiera pas votre demande
d'asile c'est impossible et donc c'est
100000 personnes qui arrivent c'est déjà
c'est une goutte d'eau puisque il faut
dire que 80% des personnes qui fument
leur pays fuient dans leur pays même
voir dans les pays limitrophes et donc
pas du tout ne viennent pas en Europe
enfin c'est rarement finalement un
objectif en soi c'est plutôt une
fatalité et donc ces personnes là de
toute façon elles seront là donc on peut
pas dire réfléchissons aux flux ou
réfléchissons à leur éloignement il
faudra étudier leur demande d'asile et
c'est 40% de taux de protection en
première instance ça l'offre pas et
c'est 30% à la Cour nationale de droit
d'asile très exactement et c'est 80% au
Royaume-Uni par exemple donc c'est aussi
pas compris la protection des donc les
100000 personnes par an qui viennent
demander l'asile il y a 40% d'entre
elles qui vont avoir une protection des
l'étude de leur demande par l'Office
française de production des réfugiés à
patrides et entre 30 et 40% ensuite
quand ils font appel de leur demande
devant la Cour nationale brodasile donc
c'est quand même un chiffre de fin c'est
des personnes qui vont qui
ne sont pas majoritairement des faux
demandeurs d'asile parce que c'était
l'un des arguments donnés j'étais l'un
des arguments de départ majoritaires
c'est difficile de dire que ce sont des
faux demandeurs d'asile de toute façon
ce sont des personnes qui ont fui des
difficultés quelles sont-elles est-ce
qu'elle relève de l'asile est-ce qu'elle
ne relève pas de l'asile c'est le
travail de lovepra et de la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile par ailleurs
les mesures d'éloignement alors donc
c'est encore autre chose c'est une fois
qu'on est plus dans les demandeurs
d'asile et donc du coup on est plus du
tout dans la question de la répartition
géographique on s'éloigne justement ce
que vous disiez là l'État n'a pas la
main pour dire à quelqu'un vous allez
vous installer ici voilà se présente à
une frontière il a dit je demande
l'asile le pays est obligé de lui ouvrir
sa frontière est obligé ensuite de
l'accueillir dans des conditions de
vigne digne donc ça veut dire voilà
exactement pour les autres finalement
des personnes privées des tapent pas
leur dire vous allez allez vous
installer en pleine campagne
c'est l'immigration familiale donc on va
c'est quelqu'un qui par exemple retrouve
une famille donc la personne a déjà
prouvé que son logement
a été cohérent avec le regroupement etc
donc ils vont pas les déplacer ensuite
l'immigration économique c'est un lien
avec un travail donc on peut pas le
déplacer mais tu en non plus donc la
seule répartition possible c'est une
demandeur d'asile et ceux qui deviennent
réfugiés après qui parfois aussi
prennent des places dans les centres
d'hébergement qui sont actuellement à
hauteur de 50 000 après l'objectif et de
50 000 en France alors je vais vous
donner la parole tout de suite mais je
voudrais quand même
entendre un maire de petites communes
justement de communes rurales Didier
Sénégal qui est maire de Gia on est dans
le Puy de Dôme
797 habitants c'est ça je crois
bonjour à vous bonsoir à vous tous vous
vous avez un cada un centre d'accueil
pour les demandeurs d'asile dans votre
commune c'est ça tout à fait depuis
plusieurs années est-ce que ça a été le
choix du mail ou votre choix ou
respectueux je vous ai interrompu
excusez-moi est-ce que ça va être ça a
été votre choix ou le choix de votre
prédécesseur ou est-ce que ça vous a été
entre guillemets imposé
non non ça a été plus ou moins imposé
entre guillemets par la préfecture et
donc et les services de la préfecture
qui nous ont dit vous avez des logements
donc de type HLM vacants et donc il
serait bien que vous puissiez accueillir
en assistant un petit peu donc on a
accepté le conseil municipal s'est réuni
et accepter donc cette proposition on a
donc actuellement 33 places de cada
répartie entre deux ou trois pavillons
sur un petit lotissement office HLM et
des logements dans un bâtiment collectif
et alors combien de personnes d'abord
est-ce que ce sont des familles est-ce
que sont plutôt des hommes seuls et puis
peut-être la question va avec comment ça
se passe quel bilan vous vous en tirez
alors nous on avait posé entre
guillemets une condition si on avait
voilà en disant on veut bien accepter
mais on voudrait que ça soit des
familles et si possible des familles
avec enfants pourquoi parce qu'on est
dans un milieu rural profond une commune
de 800 habitants en pleine zone
Puy-de-Dôme limite creuse voilà on a des
services publics ce qui avait fait
penché le choix de la préfecture pour
nous c'est qu'on a l'ensemble des
services publics médecins pharmacie etc
on est éloignés par contre la métropole
on est à 60 km de Clermont-Ferrand et
c'est peut-être le la seule difficulté
c'est que pour se déplacer pour les pour
tout ce qui est administratif il faut
faire 60 km et s'apposer un petit peu de
problèmes
ça nous a quand même permis que l'État
et la région puisque c'est la région qui
est maintenant des considères accepte de
mettre en place une ligne on avait une
ligne de train qui avait disparu mettent
en place une ligne de bus
régulière chaque jour qui nous permet de
rejoindre la métropole ce qu'on avait
demandé depuis fort longtemps et
si vous voulez l'afflux de demande sur
ce service a permis d'avoir de faire
fléchir la région et de octroyer une
ligne de bus ça a eu un autre effet
c'est que on a quand même des enfants
qui renforcent l'effectif scolaire
de manière relativement importante
puisqu'on a sur 33 places on a une
dizaine d'enfants qui ces variables
parce que ce sont des gens qui attendent
de l'OFPRA leur papier ou en tout cas
une réponse et donc ils sont pas là tout
le temps mais c'est remplacé très
régulièrement et alors donc ça on va
dire c'est plutôt dans la colonne plus
si vous deviez faire je sais pas s'il y
en a une mais une colonne moins quels
ont été les soucis s'il y en a eu
il y en a eu très très peu on a eu une
un retour négatif d'une personne qui m'a
même menacé puisqu'on a fini au tribunal
bon qui avait une orientation politique
qui faisait que il ne pouvait accepter
dans son esprit la venue de réfugiés
mais
on n'a pas eu de difficultés quelques
petites incivilités d'enfants par
exemple mais bon c'est j'allais dire on
a les mêmes quelquefois avec des enfants
tout à fait français donc
la plus grosse difficulté si vous voulez
être pour eux c'est de s'adapter quand
ils arrivent vraiment de zone soit de
zone de guerre soit de zone très
profondes où ils ont pas la notion même
de
d'appartements de choses comme ça il y a
une sociabilisation qui est compliquée
pour eux mais on a quand même deux
personnes qui sont donc qui font partie
de l'administration de forum que j'ai
posé et qui prennent en charge des gens
là et qui leur apprennent on a des
bénévoles qui leur apportent des cours
de français enfin voilà on n'a pas de
difficultés importantes on n'a pas de
difficultés même
pour accueillir ces gens-là alors restez
avec nous Monsieur le Maire j'aurais une
autre question à vous poser tout à
l'heure Mathieu est-ce que notre société
puisque Alexandre de lecture disait tout
à l'heure bah là les Français qu'est-ce
qu'ils demandent ils demandent plutôt
qu'on arrête le flux est-ce que
finalement il y a une aussi une partie
de la société française qui peut-être
pas aussi fermée ou au style aux
migrants qu'on imagine je pense pas que
ce soit la question quand on parle de la
question de l'accueil des des réfugiés
donc et demandeurs d'asile en milieu
rural ou ailleurs je pense que les gens
ne se posent pas cette question là quand
ils rencontrent ces réfugiés demandeurs
d'asile moi j'ai fait une étude sur
l'intégration des réfugiés dans les
zones rurales territoire en France
travaille beaucoup société sur aussi au
niveau européen ce que j'entends de
Monsieur je l'ai entendu à multiples
reprises en fait tout le temps dans
toutes les parties rurales c'est-à-dire
il y a plusieurs ruralités en France
alors c'est beaucoup dans ce centre de
la France et le Sud-Ouest mais même dans
d'autres territoires plutôt dans le
nord-est ou l'est peut-être avec des
peut-être plus plus fermés sur les
questions de migration parce que il y a
eu aussi une migration importante
historiquement dans ces territoires là
donc et je pense et la spécificité de
cet accueil en milieu rural c'est qu'il
y a finalement une forte mobilisation de
la population et ça ça m'a beaucoup
marqué les
réfugiés sont toujours accompagnés de
quelqu'un dans de la population il y a
eu quelques mouvements de quelques
expressions d'hostilité au début et ce
que les mers souvent m'ont dit c'est que
très rapidement c'est hostilité c'est tu
au moins et parfois même ce sont devenus
les bénévoles les plus actifs et donc ça
c'est on voit très bien dans quelle
mesure la population de ces petites
villes
accueillent ces personnes dans leur
communauté la communauté villageoise il
y a ce sentiment d'appartenance qui se
développe très vite aussi pour les
réfugiés qui se sentent Corréziens je
vous conseille en Corrèze attendait des
migrants qui ont été dans des campements
à Calais c'est à dire on est corrézien
et ils sont Corréziens ils travaillent
là-bas
si c'est celle que vous allez poser
ensuite Homer et je ne sais pas si elle
est tabou mais par exemple les 33
personnes qui sont inclinées sur lequel
nationalité et de quelle religion il y a
ça derrière votre question et ben on va
lui poser la question Didier Sénégal il
y a cette question ils sont de quelle
nationalité peut-être de quelle religion
et et aussi elle va avec enfin moi elle
m'intéresse aussi c'est est-ce qu'il
reste c'est à dire où est-ce qu'il y a
une sorte de turnover permanent quoi
alors
les nationalités sont très variables et
on a eu des périodes avec des gens de
l'Albanie Roumanie etc avec on pensait
peut-être même des filières qui
permettaient à ces gens d'arriver en
France on a eu des gens de l'Est on a eu
des
Ukrainiens des Géorgiens
actuellement on a pas mal d'Africains
l'origine d'Afrique centrale beaucoup
donc des gens déjà de couleur ce qui est
dans un milieu très rural
dénoter un petit peu avec des
habillements quelquefois des habits un
petit peu différents évidemment de nous
Européens
ont été un peu surpris mais en fait
compte ça se passe très bien il y a on
voit des gens en boubou ce promener dans
les rues et faire leur cours et en fait
il y a pas de hostilité latente qui
apparaît donc par contre pour répondre à
votre question on a des gens qui sont
restés on a des gens qui sont
parfaitement intégrés et moi je reprends
ce que disait le maire donc au début de
votre émission on a eu des enfants de
très très haut niveau qui ont
parfaitement réussi puisque ça fait
plusieurs années on a des enfants qui
ont eu des bacs avec mention alors
qu'ils étaient non francophones quand
ils arrivaient et on a des gens qui se
sont installés moi j'ai une famille là
sur la commune qui a acheté une maison
qui a trouvé du travail
les pouces travaillent à la maison de
retraite le monsieur travaille dans une
scierie ils ont quatre enfants il y en a
deux qui font des études supérieures à
Clermont-Ferrand donc vous voyez c'est
c'est des gens qui qui sont parfaitement
intégrés et je pardon parce que le temps
file je reviendrai sûrement vers vous
une dernière fois dans ce débat je vous
redonne la parole Alexandre de viechio
parce que je vous entendais tickets sur
l'histoire des services publics tout à
l'heure qu'est-ce qui vous fait tiquer
bon c'est très bien que vous ayez une
ligne de bus mais je comprends pas
qu'elle soit pas arrivée avant pourquoi
ça doit être corrélé à l'arrivée de de
Migros et ce qui me gêne un peu aussi
dans cette politique et c'est pour ça je
crois qu'à l'angoisse une partie des des
Français qui habillent dans assaisonnes
là
c'est l'idée que que finalement ils sont
oubliés
mais là parce qu'il y a de l'immigration
on va leur on va leur installer une
ligne de bus et que la seule solution à
apporter à leurs problèmes c'est
finalement d'être revitalisé par
l'immigration peut-être qu'on peut aussi
installer des hôpitaux créer des lignes
de bus sont nécessairesment le fait
qu'il y ait d'immigration après j'écoute
ce qui était dit je pars de principe que
effectivement quand on fait venir des
individus qui sont en minorité n'importe
quel individu
intégré mais encore une fois je pense
que tout ça serait mieux accepté s'il y
avait quand même une remise à plat sur
la politique des réfugiés parce que moi
j'insiste je pense qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de migrants économiques je
pense qu'il y a énormément de recours en
fait ça a été dit et qu'il faut que des
gens qui vont être déboutés à la fin
reste pendant des années sur le
territoire et que ça ça peut être remis
remis à plat et qu'ensuite allez
effectivement on acceptera mieux ce type
de politique est-ce que peut-être pour
revenir sur le débat qui était sur
l'immigration mais sur l'accueil dans
dans les zones rurales oui en fait ce
que vous suggérez c'est finalement aussi
d'envoyer des Français dans un orage des
obligés parce que je sais pas si vous
savez comment le faire des enfants par
exemple et d'avoir des services publics
c'est c'est s'il y a des services
publics il y aura plus facilement des
enfants vous voyez aussi le
les services publics vont aussi l'argent
de l'État les dotations de l'État elles
vont aussi là où il y a de la population
et je veux dire or si je peux terminer
mes phrases par exemple
l'investissement de l'État par habitant
et souvent plus élevé dans les zones
rurales qu'elle est dans dans les
grandes villes et je ne le conteste pas
mais c'est la réalité donc l'état
fonctionne comme ça la question des
nationalismes l'investissement de l'État
en général et plus élevé par habitant
d'accord par habitant on parle par
habitant
donc et c'est normal moi je trouve que
c'est normal c'est la solidarité
nationale et je pense que c'est
important pour un pays comme la France
d'avoir cette solidarité nationale donc
c'est là où c'est très confus ce que
vous disiez aussi j'ai appris que les
Vietnamiens étaient plus proches de moi
culturellement que les Syriens c'est
c'est je suis content de l'apprendre ce
soir donc la question des nationalités
et la question des différences je l'ai
aussi beaucoup vu dans dans les
entretiens j'ai pu avoir avec des
bénévoles je parle même pas avec les
bénévoles enfin les travailleurs
d'associations ou l'état c'est souvent
une question avant et moi j'ai vu c'est
plutôt des Syriens qui sont arrivés
musulmans
parfois voil pour les femmes et en fait
très rapidement c'est une question qui
ne sait plus poser et c'est pour ça
aussi ce que je vous disais la question
de l'immigration elle se pose plus la
question c'est on a telle famille avec
telle Monsieur Madame untel untel avec
des enfants et je pense que le fait que
les familles soient importants et c'est
ça qui compte et donc la question de
finalement la diversité religieuse moi
je l'ai entendu surtout par rapport à la
nourriture à la seule préoccupation et
en France on est quand même dans un pays
où on a cette diversité un peu partout
et on peut trouver la nourriture à elle
partout et c'est une question pendant le
covid on va avoir un chapitre sur le on
va dire l'impact politique Laetitia de
cette proposition d'Emmanuel Macron ça
agit très clairement comme un détonateur
pour la droite très clairement d'Éric
Ciotti de vos néo retailleux jusqu'à
Éric Zemmour ce fut une levée de
boucliers direct avec surenchères de
mots chocs regardez par exemple
Eric Ciotti sur Twitter qui écrit
vouloir déplacer les problèmes liés à
l'immigration vers les zones rurales est
une hérésie et une lâcheté Macron
continue son entreprise de
déconstruction de la nation la seule
solution courageuse et d'arrêter
l'immigration de masse et c'est vrai que
l'idée que vous développez à l'essence
de Bécaud et largement diffusé par la
droite il faut arrêter l'immigration à
moi-même de se demander où on place les
migrants alors son concurrent à la
présidence LR chef de fil des sénateurs
Bruno Retailleau lui a carrément dit que
la politique d'Emmanuel Macron allait
mener au désastre pas de réaction de la
part d'Aurélien Pradier vous savez le
troisième concurrent LR qui est plutôt
plus modéré quant à Éric Zemmour alors
là il a bu son petit lait il a même été
le premier à réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux en proclamant Emmanuel Macron le
dit haut et fort le grand remplacement
et pour lui une nécessité il a même
écrit à tous les maires ruraux pour les
prévenir de l'Apocalypse prochaine et du
côté du rassemblement national c'est
exactement la mais sans les mêmes mots
puisque Marine Le Pen ne peut pas
reprendre à son compte le mantra du
Grand remplacement d'Éric Zemmour et
donc elle le fait autrement on va
écouter par exemple un extrait de son
discours c'était aux universités d'été à
Agde
serait-il tenté de vider Paris
de ce courrier de d'Éric Zemmour
si vous l'aviez en face vous le diriez
quoi
monsieur Zemmour
déjà j'hésiterais à lui parler mais
ensuite je lui dirai ce que je vous ai
dit c'est que la venue de
vendeur d'asile en milieu rural ne crée
pas de zone de ghetto ne crée pas de
choses comme ça dans un milieu très
rural à condition évidemment que le
quota
immigré population locale reste correct
qui est ici avoir une assimilation
facile et qu'on ne crée pas non plus une
zone d'habitation concentrée nous on a
l'avantage d'avoir deux zones avec une
répartition sur le bourg
merci beaucoup merci de votre témoignage
je rappelle que vous êtes le maire de
Gia dans le dans le Puy-de-Dôme un tout
petit peu moins de 800 habitants c'était
très intéressant d'avoir votre retour de
de terrain
tanière à chaux est-ce que il y a quand
même des chiffres par exemple les
chiffres de Frontex qui nous dit que le
nombre d'entrée irrégulières est au plus
haut en Europe depuis 2016 sont les
chiffres sont tombés aujourd'hui ça on
peut considérer que ça ne va pas
s'arranger avec par exemple les réfugiés
climatiques dans les dans les prochaines
années est-ce que pour vous c'est
illusoire de leur fermer la porte ou
est-ce que finalement c'est pas une
vraie question qui correspond comme le
dit Alexandre véhicault comme le dit une
partie de la droite qu'elle soit à
droite de gouvernement traditionnel ou
droite extrême qu'il faut vraiment
prendre un bras le corps mais alors
c'est une question complexe parce que on
a l'impression que agir au niveau
français permettrait dans les politiques
de tarir les flux qui sont mentionnés or
la réalité et que les personnes partent
de leur pays parce qu'il y a des
problèmes dans leur pays d'origine et
donc là dessus c'est quand même beaucoup
plus compliqué d'agir sur des conflits
sur des guerres alors sur des questions
climatiques ça c'est intéressant parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne reconnaît pas
on ne donne pas l'asile à des personnes
qui fuient pour des motifs climatiques
donc ça va alors sur les questions
climatiques il y a vraiment tout un
enjeu particulier peut-être que je le
laisse de côté mais on va pas y rentrer
en interne dans ce qui proposait parce
que ce que propose ce que décrit
Alexandre lecture ou ce que propose des
élus de droite est-ce que c'est pas
illusoire c'est-à-dire c'est le voilà
c'est le mur face à de toute façon un
mouvement exactement
illusoire et en fait qu'est-ce que aussi
il faut juste se dire à la frontière
bien sûr c'est le problème d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est des rendu conduction à la
frontière qui sont pas effectués alors
attention parce que ils produisent aussi
des mesures d'éloignement à l'égard par
exemple du Kenya ou d'afghan bien sûr
qu'elles sont pas effectivement suite
qui va qui va les reconduire et même
comment est-ce qu'on le ferait donc il y
a aussi cette problématique là qui est
jamais adressée en amont et ensuite vous
redonne la parole c'est marrant sur
l'immigration à effectivement évolué je
dirais de chaque côté du corps politique
avant nous on m'aurait opposé le fait
que mais non il y a pas tellement
d'immigration etc maintenant le
phénomène est tellement immense qu'on ne
peut plus rien faire on est totalement
appui sur si on veut nourrir les
extrêmes il y a pas de meilleur
politique que ça si on pose votre
raisonnement jusqu'au bout il y a
beaucoup de pays en guerre il y a
beaucoup de pays où il y a des problèmes
économiques si on accueille le monde
entier en réalité il y a plus d'Europe
il y a plus d'Europe et il y a plus de
richesse même pour ceux qui arrivent à
leur transmettre donc je pense qu'il
faut au contraire c'est un enjeu
politique moi je crois en la politique
et je pense que un pays doit être de ses
frontières il y a des pays où il y a pas
de l'immigration du tout je dis pas que
c'est souhaitable mais le Japon alors
vous allez me dire c'est une île mais je
pourrais vous citer d'autres exemples
donc je crois qu'il y a des oui c'est
une question politique il faut se donner
les moyens de la résoudre politiquement
alors quand je posais cette question je
vous ai entendu dire ces tuto pistes oui
c'est le le l'utopie elle est de vouloir
stopper totalement l'immigration c'est
une autopise ça n'arrivera jamais ce
n'est jamais arrivé ça n'arrivera jamais
que ça soit souhaitable ou pas ça peut
être discutable en tout cas c'est une
autopédie donc après on peut être
pragmatique on peut pays qui accueille
beaucoup moins voire pas alors la France
est plutôt si on prend les pays de
l'OCDE ou encore désolé moi je suis
chercheur donc je regarde les chiffres
aussi le pays la France parce que les
chiffres de 80% ça vous intéressait pas
du reste je vous ai parlé
il y a pas eu de plomb en campagne il me
semble donc on voit que il y a des
chiffres que vous vous acceptez d'autre
part
exacte de ce 80%
des ministres de l'intérieur
du ministère d'intérieur je les ai pas
trouvé bref on va pas refaire ce débat
allez au bout de la démonstration donc
si on prend les les chiffres à la France
c'est de du ministère de l'Intérieur
français et euh
CDE on est sur plutôt une Fauchère basse
en France on est plutôt les flux donc
sont bas par rapport à un accueille
moins que d'autres pays de l'OCDE
d'accord par rapport à la population
bien sûr qu'on accueille plus que le
Liechtenstein mais par rapport à la
population on est plutôt sur sur un taux
plutôt bas en France et puis on prend
jamais aussi dans les chiffres de
l'immigration on parle jamais de ceux
qui partent parce que c'est aussi une
réalité y compris des Français Martin
donc on a on a on a plutôt un seul de
migratoire qui est relativement faible
après il y a une question politique moi
je suis pas politique pour que les gens
comprennent le seul de migratoire
effectivement c'est les gens qui partent
donc les Français qui partent en
Angleterre ou ailleurs souvent les
cerveaux et les gens qui arrivent donc
les mêmes types de population donc si on
sentait au sol demi on n'a pas les
résultats en faire beaucoup de choses
est-ce que je peux parler merci et une
autre particularité la France c'est que
les Français partent de plus en plus et
reviennent c'est aussi une particularité
de la France par rapport aux Allemands
ou britanniques ou partent aussi à
l'aventure trouver à d'autres aventures
ailleurs et ils reviennent et les
Français reviennent beaucoup plus que
les Allemands le regard le regard je
vous interrompre ce que je voudrais
proposer un dernier témoignage et c'est
celui de Benoît Hamon ancien candidat à
la présidentielle très malheureux on
s'en souvient il est vraiment pas
recueilli beaucoup de suffrages il est
devenu directeur général d'une ONG qui
s'appelle single global qui œuvre pour
l'inclusion économique des personnes
déplacées je l'avais reçu en novembre
dernier sur la chaîne économique
Bismarck lui dit il faut changer le
regard sur même pas seulement les
réfugiés ou de demandeurs d'asile sur ce
qu'on appelle les migrants
un des objectifs de Singa c'est de
changer le regard des sociétés
accueillantes sur ces personnes qui
migrent c'est de révéler le potentiel de
ces femmes et ses hommes et pas les
réduire à leur trajectoire migratoire
d'ailleurs dans la manière dont on parle
des migrations on dit les migrants comme
si une personne se réduisait à ces
quelques mois parfois c'est plus long ça
peut être plusieurs années qu'elle a
passé sur la route exilé de force
souvent contre son gré avant d'arriver
chez nous derrière il y a des
enseignants il y a des artisans il y a
que sais-je encore des chefs
d'entreprise qui ont un potentiel
indiscutable et si ce potentiel est
révélé c'est une chance incroyable pour
les sociétés d'accueil en disant cela je
sais que spontanément ça a heurte des
idées majoritaires de la société
française pourtant je vous redonne des
chiffres même si ces chiffres ne
convaincre pas à eux tout seul ce qui
résiste à cette idée 43% des créateurs
d'entreprises de tech en Allemagne sont
des personnes réfugiées aux migrantes
50% des licornes américaines ont
valorisé à plus d'un milliard d'euros
ont été créés par des immigrés aux
États-Unis
Alexandre devecchio je vais terminer
avec vous les migrants ont aussi des
talents un potentiel économique on peut
aussi le reconnaître personne ne Nissa
je suis fils de d'immigrer arriver
d'ailleurs du Portugal clandestinement
personne ne dit ça à chaque individu je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure moi je crois à
l'intégration peut s'intégrer à
condition qu'il adapte les codes et la
culture de qui s'adapte au code et à la
culture de la de la population d'origine
et à condition que tout cela soit
maîtrisé parce que comme la reconnu
lui-même le maire il veut bien
accueillir quelques personnes
minoritaires avec les moyens pour s'en
occuper mais il voudrait pas le débat
HLM chez lui et donc je pense que
justement la politique a dérapé a créé
une concentration de population sur dans
les zones en banlieue mais pas seulement
et que la politique d'intégration n'est
pas possible aujourd'hui et menace la
cohésion nationale donc je pense qu'il
faut remettre tout ça à plat et
éventuellement continuer d'accueillir et
d'intégrer ensuite quand tout ça et sera
un peu plus dépassionné un mot de
conclusion obtenir un chaud 30 secondes
et ben j'aimerais bien savoir
[Musique]
concret parce qu'en réalité ça existe
déjà la question de la répartition et je
pense que tout simplement en fait c'est
augmenter les chiffres de cette
répartition puisque aujourd'hui c'est
2500 personnes par mois qui sont
réorientés en Île-de-France pour qu'on
puisse avoir une idée concrète donc donc
voilà je suis plutôt intrigué 2023 donc
on va on n'a pas beaucoup à attendre
exactement on verra ce qui est dit très
concrètement pour l'instant
c'est du déjà déjà en place bon merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat et d'avoir pris même si
c'était enlevé le voilà le temps de
l'écoute des uns et des autres tenir la
chose rappelle le titre de votre livre
politique immigration et réfugiée c'est
aux éditions Enrique je vous dis à lundi
je vous souhaite un bon week-end sur
Public Sénat et puis dès demain matin
Oriane mansini qui sera en direct d'Agen
pour une émission spéciale sur les
assises des départements de France et
c'est à partir de 7h30 comme d'habitude
belle soirée et bon weekend
[Musique]